this is Startalk Wilbur casks what is
the biggest stumbling block for NASA to
get funding is it stubborn legislators
science illiteracy or other factors
what's the best way we can change it
nice I think that NASA does it does get
funding we always could use more yeah I
think it's general you know yeah but I
think it's just how we how we value
things you know if we would value the
science that comes out of the space
program more I think people would be
willing to to pay more for it
exploration International I think a lot
of people don't understand all the
things that NASA does what are what are
like internet let's take one thing
International Cooperation you know might
I think of NASA with International
Cooperation but a lot of this the
science programs we have particularly
International Space Station is internet
it's called the International very hard
to make friends with a Russian on this
planet but if you just go a little into
space everybody's friendly well look
about when I was a kid we weren't
necessarily front friends with the
Russians the Soviet Union in the US or
in a Cold War and yeah we fly into space
with these people all the time these
were really good friends with them I
think that's one benefit that people
don't realize the other thing everybody
for me science is important and I love
science and a science guy after all
but what the space program brings us is
this optimism when you have a space
program no matter what country you are
you believe your society believes many
people believe that any problem can be
solved if you can put a man on the moon
we can make a car that goes over a
thousand miles we can do anything and
this is why all these countries you
might not think of of having space
programs that you fly with yeah South
Africa what have you Australia on the
back of the Canadian Brazil Brazil has a
space program yeah para the tone of his
voice he was a Jewess no no believe it
crazy Wow yes because they know the
value of having people running around in
your society doing space solving space
problems yeah and the thing for me as
the executive
CEO of the Planetary Society is George
yeah well is Planetary Sciences where
these new problems are being solved
trying to land a car on Mars is an
extraordinary undertaking and so when
you go to solve problems that have never
been solved before you just innovate
can't be helped so that's the the value
is selling politicians of all sides of
the of the executive the judicial and
the and the congressional representative
on the value of space exploration so
that's that because the last part of
that question was what's the best way we
can change it what are like say there
are three things not voting vote on the
the way that people vote on particular
issues vote on the issue of science
that's right well especially space
science it's base size yes so people say
why are you exploring Mars what are you
gonna find there we don't know that's
why we're exploring we're gonna probably
find the technology to make even better
cell phones that's people know that's
that's absolutely correct yeah yeah
people do have a voice in this for
example the Hubble Space Telescope which
was I think a very good combination of
human spaceflight and planetary science
forgery oh yeah all the smart people
come up with the discovery it had some
problems too why that's wrong exit
that's really had canceled the last
servicing mission that I was lucky to be
on they had canceled it and they got
protect mainly because of public outrage
and politicians listening and I'm bill
I'm sure as a big part of that yeah they
wanted Hubble fixed if we could only
have a voice we could only trick
al-qaeda into bombing something in outer
space we'd be that was what started the
whole thing was the ultimate high ground
we digress yes so vote person on the who
asked the question and let's change the
world